bonjour à tous bienvenue chez cuisine
mode d'emploi dijon
comme pour toute rentrée des classes il
ya de la solennité du côté de la
direction et une pointe d'appréhension
chez les stagiaires
cette formation est la promesse d'un
nouveau départ pour ses élèves ce qui ne
va pas son précieux j'aimerais faire mes
preuves et c'est vrai que je vais
arriver avec beaucoup de stress j'étais
un peu douteux mais en voyant l'équipe
qui va nous encadrer je suis sûr qu'on
ne peut que réussir et voilà on a
beaucoup de chance d'être là je pense
moi j'ai fait 22 c'est sûr avec mes
élèves 90% ont retrouvé du travail donc
je veux dire no stress par contre on est
un peu dur je vous dis franchement on va
pas vous lâcher
les voilà prévenus florian florentin
siem mohamed
ils sont dix ils ont entre 20 et 50 2
ans et il s'apprête à apprendre à
fabriquer toutes sortes de pains à
façonner des viennoiseries à faire de la
pâte à chou sans oublier des fougasses
ou des quiches le tout en semaine
seulement huit semaines à l'école et
trois semaines en entreprise
autant dire qu'ils ont du pain sur la
planche et ça les formateurs ne leur
cache pas prendre quelqu'un qui qui ne
connaît rien au départ à notre métier et
qui au bout du compte au bout de ses
huit semaines sera capable
éventuellement de rivaliser peut-être
avec des gens qui ont un simple et c'est
vraiment un challenge pour nous comme
pour eux d'ailleurs c'est aussi ce qui a
séduit certains stagiaires une formation
express est gratuite je suis pas
vraiment courant donc ça m'intéresse de
ce soir c'est rapide et puis
de vraiment aller à l'essentiel l'école
avait reçu 50 demandes
ces dix stagiaires ont été choisis sur
leur motivation et leur projet
professionnel et ils ont vécu leur
premier moment d'émotion avec la remise
de leur tenue